thanks to the release of the suicide
squad the villain known as bloodsport
has taken
center stage in the dc eu but just who
is this rampaging rascal and
why is he such a big deal in the world
of comics this
is the untold truth of bloodsport we're
all gonna die
i hope so oh for god's sake
the original bloodsport is robert dubois
a madman who kills
dozens of innocent metropolis citizens
during a rampage that unfolds in
superman volume 2 number 4.
dubois commands a seemingly endless
arsenal of high-tech weaponry
that he can teleport into his grasp
including a pistol that fires slivers of
kryptonite
he is portrayed as perpetually enraged
vietnam war veteran
often yelling at his victims that
they're wasting the freedom he
fought to preserve after bloodsport's
initial attack on a restaurant in which
he massacres over two dozen civilians
superman gets involved in corners dubois
in a bowling alley
bloodsport wounds superman with a
kryptonite bullet but thankfully jimmy
olsen's timely intervention
saves kalel from certain death in the
meantime the fact that bloodsport is
access to kryptonite leads superman to
correctly deduce that dubois sponsor
is none other than lex luthor it's jimmy
olsen who figures out the key to
defeating bloodsport when his research
leads him to the discovery that the
villain
never actually served in vietnam when
his number came
up he fled to canada and his younger
brother mickey went to vietnam in his
place
losing his arms and legs for his trouble
dubois's guilt
drove him mad and turned him into
bloodsport
jimmy finds mickey and brings him to the
battle where he pleads with bloodsport
to stop his rampage
bloodsport collapses in tears at the
sight of his brother and the gunman is
sent to a maximum security psychiatric
facility
of course that's not the last of
bloodsport not
by a long shot adventures of superman
number 507
opens with a heavily armed masked man
who calls himself bloodsport
interrupting a mugging in a metropolis
alleyway as he kills two of the three
muggers you may believe
he's a crime fighter with less forgiving
tactics similar to marvel's punisher
but when he cuts down the victim of the
mugging too things start to become a
little clearer
this is alex trent a white supremacist
dedicated to killing as many people of
color as he can
the story bleeds into action comics
number 694 and over the course of both
issues the new bloodsport kills even
more innocence than his predecessor
mostly people of color though he's also
happy to turn his
violent attentions to whites he despises
for consorting with other races
with the arrival of the cyborg villain
high tech it's revealed that both she
and bloodsport are pawns of the demon
blood thirst
bloodsport is presumed dead following an
explosion at the end of action comics
number 694 but
the following year in action comics
number 702
he returns to continue his racist
rampage just as jimmy olsen is key to
defeating the original bloodsport
it's another daily planet employee
reporter ron troop who locates trent's
achilles heel
like dubois before him trent teleports
his weapons to his hands though
his teleporter is implanted in his chest
so no one can take it from him
however troop tracks down bloodsport's
weapons cash and destroys it leaving
nothing for the races to fight with
superman captures trent who is
subsequently sent to stryker's island
prison
in 1995's adventures of superman number
526
robert dubois falls victim to the most
devastating villain of all
budget cuts needing to siphon off some
of its patience the psychiatric facility
where dubois is being treated has
transferred him to striker's island
prison
the same prison alex trent was said to
after his latest series of killings
dubois and trent are destined to collide
and things don't go well for
either of them hoping to ease tensions
in his prison
the striker's island warden agrees to a
boxing match between the two bloodsports
with the proviso that superman acts as a
referee the man of steel
agrees though he accurately deduces that
allowing the boxing match probably isn't
a great idea in the first place
the match itself doesn't last very long
dubois easily dominates trent in its
early stages after which trent tackles
his opponent
to the ground but when superman pulls
the boxers apart trent reveals a gun
as it turns out his aryan brotherhood
allies have managed to get him a new
cache of weapons
a riot quickly erupts and superman must
struggle to control the rampaging
prisoners while trying to get a hold of
dubois and trent
dubois manages to get trent's gun from
him and even escapes past the walls of
the prison but
he's quickly gunned down and killed by
the guards trent
survives the riot but not for long his
aryan brotherhood buddies learn that at
one point
during the chaos superman had to save
trent from dubois ashamed that a black
man got the better of trent the
brotherhood
burns trent to death in his cell the
third version of bloodsport to appear in
the comics has so far proven to be the
most
mysterious unlike the late robert dubois
and alex trent he doesn't make any claim
about twisted ideals serving as his
inspiration
and like many super villains he seems to
don his red skull cap mask
purely for the money during the late
2000s bloodsport appears as one of the
five villains hired to kill the man of
steel by the criminal organization
intergang the others being riot silver
banshee livewire and helgermite
this story is part of dc's one year
later event in which superman's powers
are just beginning to return after a
battle with superboy prime
superman's narration indicates that this
bloodsport's techniques are at least a
little different from those of his
predecessors and suggests that the
teleportation he uses to retrieve his
weapons is
extra dimensional in nature in spite of
his weakened state
superman is eventually able to defeat
the five villains
this new bloodsport's name is never
revealed but it's clear he's more of a
mercenary than the villains who
previously took the name
he expresses excitement at the money
offered for superman's life particularly
after some of his comrades have been
defeated and he realizes he could get a
bigger piece of the pie
this bloodsport's given name has yet to
be revealed and since one year later
most of his appearances have come in the
form of cameos bloodsport made his mark
on the dc
animated universe in the mid-2000s
though in a relatively
minor role in 2005 he made his first
appearance on justice league unlimited
in season 2's
the cat in the canary the episode
revolves around a metabrawl run by the
entrepreneurial villain roulette
in this epic showdown super villains and
heroes fight for sport
some of them against their will here
bloodsport is introduced
briefly as he's locking horns with the
batman bad guy electrocutioner it isn't
clear whether or not bloodsport survives
the events of justice league unlimited
though it seems unlikely while he's
usually only seen in the background
bloodsport is a member of the legion of
doom in the series but when the legion
of doom's spaceship is destroyed by
darkseid
in the show's penultimate episode it
isn't revealed whether or not
bloodsports survives
his death is implied however as he isn't
one of the villains saved by star
sapphire
and sinestro it's never really made
clear exactly
who this version of bloodsport is
supposed to be his given name isn't
revealed
and the unnamed version of bloodsport
had yet to appear in dc's comics at the
time the series was produced
for the time being this has to be
chalked up as yet another unsolved
bloodsport mystery
before idris elba took the role in the
suicide squad david st
lewis played robert dubois in the season
3 premiere of cw's supergirl
however while he shares dubois name
there are significant differences
between this bloodsport
and the villain from the source material
instead of covering up his draft dodging
like the original bloodsport
supergirl's version does have a military
background which proves invaluable in
his job as a terrorist for hire
meet robert dubois goes by bloodsport
which is
not any sport i've ever heard of
bloodsport first locks horns with
supergirl in the cold open of
girl of steel when she joins the
national city police in pursuit of
dubois and his goons
while he doesn't appear to have any
meta-human abilities bloodsport is
clearly close to peak human condition as
he not only survives getting knocked a
hundred yards through the air by
supergirl and crashing onto the roof of
a parked car
but he's even able to brush himself off
and escape moments later
it's later revealed that bloodsport is
working for the crooked businessman
morgan edge at edge's behest
bloodsport steals some captured alien
technology then uses it to cloak a
submarine
and attack the city's waterfront
inevitably however he's quickly defeated
by supergirl
and arrested robert dubois's time in the
afterlife comes to an end in 2021's
suicide squad number five the issue
opens with a quick recap of dubois
origin
though there's no mention of his death
in 1995's adventures of superman number
526
with all the various reboots and
reworkings dc's continuity has undergone
since 1995 it can
probably be assumed either that dubois
was resurrected by undisclosed means in
the intervening years
or that his death at striker's island
prison has been erased from history
bloodsport's role in the suicide squad
is more specific than the rest of task
force x
amanda waller sends him through a number
of different dimensions gathering
intel and recruiting new captives for
waller to use
to help him waller arms dubois with a
new suit and helmet to protect him from
the strains of interdimensional travel
as well as a nearly unlimited arsenal of
weapons that he can teleport to himself
across dimensions while a flashback
montage early in suicide squad number
five suggests that bloodsport has been
going at solo for a while
he probably won't be able to manage on
his own for long the issue finds him in
earth
3 the home of the crime syndicate a
group of supercrooks made up of sadistic
versions of the justice league heroes
by the end of the issue bloodsport is
captured by ultraman
earth 3's brutish answer to superman
forcing waller to send in a new team to
bring bloodsport home
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
your favorite movies are coming soon
subscribe to our youtube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss
a single one
you